After one month I would have $250. Well, this is below our line so that means we
saved less than $100 in a month. We started with $200 and we only gained $50. We
should have gained more than a $100. For 2 months and $500, we can see that,
that is above our line. This means we must have saved more than $100 in one of
these months. I know this because after 2 months, I should expect to have
exactly $400 if I were to have saved exactly $100 a month. But we have more. So
this one works. This one's a little bit tricky. After 1 month, I saved exactly
300 dollars. Well, this means I saved exactly 100 dollars in that 1 month. So I
didn't save more than 100 dollars. So this one's out. This point means that,
after 3 months, I saved 400 dollars. That would put me here.